is is protection a right or a privilege
so this topic was inspired
by the whale attack
so this video got taken off of my
channel um because you know sometimes
whales you know
blubber to the youtube gods
and make them take down videos even
though they consented and agreed to a
interview but you know whatever
[Music]
so so anyways um
i was interviewing this girl and she
claimed that she could not walk home
alone at night without fearing men
and i said you're not entitled to
security in a big city and that it's
dangerous for anybody
so this set her
off and ended up getting my mic like
knocked out of my hand and then she just
threw a fan they were like screaming
what would they
ah
massage the man's ego let's massage the
man's ego that's literally my favorite
part
anyways um so my question for the panel
today is is protection a right or a
privilege
and i would want everyone to go around
and say yes and you could say why
um
no because
right is it a writer a privilege oh um i
think it's a privilege okay um because
certainly we don't get protected um if
they do certain things
and to be honest i don't think anyone
deserves it you know if you act like a
dick and then someone's a bank in the
face i'm not gonna protect you so yeah
like
it's just it's one of them ones it's a
privilege that some people get and some
people don't
yeah i would agree that it's a privilege
yeah it's a privilege you have to earn
it and by the decisions you make whether
it's the streets you walk down or
where you live whatever
yeah i would also say it is a privilege
because the way i see a writer right is
something that's automatic so
if i have to compel someone to do
something then it can't necessarily be a
right um so if someone is going to
protect me i'm in a privileged position
i think it's a privilege
um
i think when it comes down to it
whatever we're dealing with
nobody
can protect us better than ourselves
so if we're expecting someone else to
protect us we're abdicating our own
responsibility to protect ourselves
at that i mean at that point
then we have to
realize okay are we what are we
surrendering to other people are we just
gonna live our life letting someone else
do our dirty work
so i think if we expect someone else to
protect us we're just being lazy honest
yeah i'm gonna agree as well i think
it's a privilege
you're not no one own owes you that no
one owes you to be to protect you and
it's funny because you said pearl in the
uh when you went interviewing people i
think you mentioned that
uh men get attacked as well there's like
a
higher percentage of men being attacked
and back in my day in my day still my
day
uh i'm still young uh back when i was
younger at least i was in a band and
were very extreme looks like big hair
and makeup and all that stuff and i used
to get beaten up all the time we used to
get followed around so it's it's true
like women think they are the only ones
who are vulnerable they are the only
ones who are being chased by men and
follow around but it's not true i used
to get bitten up all the time so uh
take that
do you think it's a man's duty to
protect um his
girlfriend or wife
yes
girlfriend or wifey okay yeah you have
to you know that's because one if you
don't she's most likely gonna leave you
and two
you know why would you want why would
you be okay with your girl or wife being
in danger if you can stop it from
happening or at least help the situation
come back to me come back to me
it's a hard one i definitely think so if
your woman's if you know if that's the
woman you picked and she's in your
corner you got to have her back
come with me so
yeah
yeah i think if you even look like
biologically like the way a man is built
he's he tends to be most of the time
stronger faster quicker
and so like just by that advantage he
has he sort of is in a better position
to protect his wife or
woman or even kids so
i would say that's a that's a
responsibility that men have women can
also protect themselves but
a man should protect yeah
i believe that a man should protect his
wife
as the mother of his child
outside of that no
exactly that's what i was thinking
and that's and i might disagree with you
no no disrespect but i might disagree
with you on the fact that because he has
more physical ability that obligates him
to protect
because
what if the world's war was reversed
what if she's a female bodybuilder and
he's just a you know a dude that works
in an office
does she now have
that obligation to protect because she's
the one more in a position to physically
repel the attack
i think
it as a man
regardless of circumstances
if this is my woman this is the woman
that prepares my meals this is the woman
that's taking care of my child
i don't want anything to happen that
moment because i want to make sure that
my home is still there tomorrow so if
anybody comes and threatens her they got
a problem with me
but if she's just my girlfriend she's a
girl that i take you know we go drinks
we have some fun
but then doesn't a woman have to be your
girlfriend before becoming your wife so
what if she's someone you want to be
your wife and then what would you just
let her get beat up because she's not
your wife yet but it depends with
pearl's question
ask it what was the original question
um what did i say is it a duty yeah is
it a duty to protect your wife or
girlfriend
as a girlfriend i wouldn't say it's a
duty like he
needs to i say he can in certain
situations he can but as a wife it's his
duty because he's in a now committed
relationship because he is married to
her but this is what i'm asking because
you know
it's like that question when people say
oh can you give wife benefits before
your wife right so the benefit of being
married is that it's my duty to protect
you right if i don't do it beforehand
i'm guessing you won't marry me when i'm
proposed
it's the duty word that it is like you
can you definitely can but if i put
myself in a situation where i am
i'm deserving of what comes to me it's
not your duty to protect me because i
put myself in that situation and in that
sense i agree with you i think the word
duty is what kind of gets me like i
think it's our default as men to be
protective but duty
i don't know i don't think anyone should
have duties you know it's not
jobs like what's a woman's duty then i
mean i i think a woman has certain
duties in the relationship but you know
i agree i agree with you i don't
disagree but it's the word duty that i
don't know if i if i would choose that
word that's all i agree with both of you
actually
um i believe that dating is practice for
marriage
okay
so
if i want that woman to marry me or want
to marry me i'm going to treat her in a
way
that gives her a preview of what it's
going to be like to be married to me so
if i just be like she
even if she's a total trash
right even if she gets really drunk and
just starts a fight with some guy at the
bar
and
if i had just met the girl i'd be like
okay see you later nice to meet you i'm
out
but if this was my woman
i've been here with her for like two
three years
you know
we're maybe talking about marriage
and
there's no way i know her family i'm
responsible to her dad
okay
now this dumb girl i gotta pull her out
of here what am i gonna do
so then i'm thinking about it then i
feel the sense of duty
like i have a responsibility to not just
her but other people that want her to
get home okay even if she's being an
idiot so